if you had a
superpower what would it be think
carefully about this
one a few moments later to
um I I would um
want um to two hours
later no one asked me that question
before see this is why this is The Mulia
we're piercing into your soul
I had the superpower if I tried to use
it and then it was like illegal I would
be in prison but then you have the
superpower and you're above the law
anyway yeah but I would want to live
life like that it's to um so I would
have to do something that I could be it
could be useful like in the real world
yeah um and that I wouldn't be in
trouble if I used it and it wouldn't be
yeah I wouldn't want to fly or anything
like that cuz I wouldn't want to go all
the way up like that I just you know I
don't want to fly okay um strength you
know I've already felt stronger than 99%
of the population so
being stronger than 100 of them won make
much
difference well played sir well
played like if there was some kind of
superpower that allowed me just like
turn on turn off whenever I want to yeah
um or my anger like you know the
emotions I have if if there was some
kind of a power that I could control cuz
I think if you can control two things
you can control your desires and you can
control your fear H I think if you
control those thing you you'll be
successful in life but what if that fear
is required at that particular point in
time yeah that's fine I mean but then
then don't control it too much leave a
little bit of it just to keep you on
edge but the sexual design the anger
these are two things that if I could
switch if I could have a button to
switch it off at certain times I would
love to be able to do that I think that
would be the most useful thing that I
could actually use as a super power cuz
if I'm going to burn somebody or
something I'm go to prison
I'm going to fly that's I thought maybe
you were going to save Gaza bro I
thought you going to do something on
your own that Muhammad is
single-handedly is going to free
Palestine now that you think about it
well can I go that can I go that far can
I it's like can of course of course you
can bro come on how am I going to
destroy a whole country with superpowers
use your imagination the Army can I
destroy Army can I destroy the United
States of America United me
down think Superman no I don't think I'd
have to train myself on those
superpowers I don't think I'd be able to
take on a whole army with a superpower
one Superman versus a 300 million Army
like we have to be honest about this
well there's no bullet that can kill him
so I mean who Superman oh no bullets I
can kill him then I live forever that's
that's that's a punishment that's not
super power well you can die because of
kryptonite I mean you could go to the
Planet Krypton and then just kill
yourself I guess I would want to do
suicide I that decision
all right fine fair enough let's go on
to the next question